what's up everyone we are sitting down
with sunny Jane from Sun genomics
hi Ellen thanks for having me on the
show I'm excited to talk about the
microbiome yeah let's do it so maybe to
first understand it let's go through a
breakdown of exactly how the DNA works
at the RNA that works with the proteins
and how exactly that works within the
body and we have a cool graphic to show
ya to teach us about this well there's
something called the the central dogma
of life so basically our our bodies are
made from a blueprint and that blueprint
is called DNA and it's sort of the
foundation and from the DNA we begin to
express things called RNA it's an
expression of that DNA building block
and from RNA you can actually create
amino acids and proteins and proteins
are put together to create some of the
cells and tissues and organs of our body
so this is really the foundation and the
central dogma of life yeah and it's
called like the central dogma I find
that to be so interesting like he says
kind of a way that the building blocks
of life gets synthesized that's right
and so everything has a code to it if
you will within our bodies and that code
begins with the DNA which is one of the
most stable components inside our visors
I mean you can get DNA extracted from
ancient mummies even today and RNA then
becomes expressed a little bit less
stable and also has lots of variability
and it's a lot more challenging to
understand that expression and then
there's the protein level and the
proteins begin to degrade over time and
and and have a denature ization
associated with them so one of the good
ways or the simplest ways to understand
life is to go to the most stable
component at the DNA level yeah and like
you said DNA gets denatured we last and
like we have this system looks exactly
what you were just saying we have a
little like breakdown graphic here too
understand it how the build-up the
synthesis of life actually ends up
occurring and then how is this
applicable to the breakdown of like the
GI tract yeah so our our bodies are now
native organs tissues and the GI tract
is responsible for digestion which is
what I want to talk to you about today
and it's related to the microbiome as
well so the first thing we do when we
got a good graphic for this as well yeah
let's take a look so the first thing we
do when we eat is is begin to chew on
that food or whatever we're digesting
and that's the first exposure to enzymes
that are going to break down food and
food that will eventually be a source
for nutrition for our bodies so we go
through a oral cavity and then through
our esophagus so the food will travel
down through the esophagus it's been
broken down a little bit and that's
gonna make it easier for that absorption
but then it hits the stomach and that's
where the real churning occurs and in
the stomach there's going to be a
release of acids and things to really
break down and stretch out any
components of the the material that's in
there so that you can you can open it up
and get the benefit of amino acids
vitamins etc that that you're eating
Ronnie I'll throw it up and we'll walk
us through as well at the same time so
yes we went from the adding our saliva
in order to like great to add enzymes
the digestive enzymes and then down the
esophagus and as a bolus a swallow goes
down the esophagus into the stomach and
then that's what you're describing all
the different acids that come in to help
break down the food bile and then and
then at that point I used to always
think that then you would get the
nutrients from there but no the
nutrients although you absorb the
nutrients through the small intestine
right yeah this is all your mouth your
teeth the enzyme it's always set up for
your intestines right it's all of the
preparation that's needed so that by the
time it crosses through the stomach and
and into
duodenum the small intestines that's
where the food is now ready to a blue
absorbed into your bloodstream and you
can actually get the nutrition from it
and that's just through the walls as it
goes so it's so it's now this like bile
broken down and totally broken down by
surface area as well and now it's
sliding through the small intestine and
it's absorbing nutrients as it goes
through the small intestine walls as
it's moving along yeah and there's a lot
of interesting mechanics that happen
along that way and one of the first
things is is bile and salts also
combining with the food to help break it
down even further but another thing
that's happened in the last well I guess
another thing that we're now beginning
to understand in the last five or six
years is just how much of that breakdown
is attributed to our microbiomes
or microbes that are actually living
inside the small intestine they're their
trillions of microbes living inside of
this small intestine and in our next
video we're going to talk about this
larger breakdown of the gut microbiome
this is a pretty good pretty good way
for us to to start understanding it so
so that's good a little bit of a
breakdown of exactly how the body's key
parts work as well as a little bit of a
breakdown of the GI tract catch us on
another one of these explanation videos
with Sun genomics soon thanks guys
thanks